no one has claimed responsibility for
the newest attack on an Iraqi air base
north of Baghdad yesterday that wounded
four members of Iraq's military now this
follows Iran's missile strike last week
on to Iraqi bases that has hundreds of
US troops this morning Holly Williams
went to one of them that's the al Asad
Air Base to get a first-hand look at the
damage
good morning this is the scene of Iran's
revenge attack against US troops here in
Iraq last week the Iranians fired 16
ballistic missiles according to the US
the majority of them targeting this
place al Asad Air Base where there are
around 1,500 US coalition troops this is
one of the buildings that was hit it was
sleeping quarters u.s. troops apparently
had just minutes to take cover after
being given warning that Iranian
missiles had been fired and you'll
remember that there were no casualties
you'll also remember that the Iranian
strikes were retaliation after President
Trump authorized the assassination by
drone strike of one of Iran's top
generals Qasem Soleimani
earlier this month now there's been
speculation that the Iranians
deliberately missed US troops in order
to avoid a further escalation in
violence with the US however a senior US
coalition military official told us that
simply isn't true that based on where
the missiles landed the Iranians were
shooting to kill in his words for CBS
this morning I'm Holly Williams on al
Asad airbase
you